My co-chair, Dr. Bob Vonderheide, and myself, we'd like to welcome you
to the Clinical Trials Plenary 3, Cellular Therapies
and Complex Immunotherapies. We're really in for a treat
with an interesting variety of clinical data this morning.
We have CAR-Ts very early in the disease state in smoldering
myeloma. We have novel CARs with early evidence of activity in
refractory solid tumors. We have a bispecific antibody with a
conditional 4-1BB agonist in MSS colorectal cancer
with clinical activity, especially at the higher doses of the 4-1BB ligand.
And we have a novel vaccine targeting PD-L1 and IDO
plus pembrolizumab for myeloma.
Now I'm going to turn over the mic to my co-chair, Dr. Vonderheide.
Thank you, James, and welcome everybody to the plenary session.
I'm Bob Vonderheide. I'm the director of the Abramson Cancer Center at the
University of Pennsylvania, and
in two hours, I become president-elect of AACR.
So pretty exciting year for me.
Thank you.
Thank you all for coming to the annual meeting. We'll jump right in.
I'll introduce our first speaker, who is Dr.
Omar Nadeem from the Dana-Farber Cancer Institute, who will give us
results of the CAR-PRISM trial.
Thank you. Good morning, everyone.
Thank you to the organizers for choosing our abstract for this plenary
presentation. And on behalf of my co-investigator, it's my pleasure to share
results of ciltacept gene autolysin in patients with high-risk smoldering
myeloma, results from the CAR-PRISM trial.
These are my disclosures.
So high-risk smoldering myeloma is a precursor plasma cell neoplasm that carries
approximately a 50% chance of progression to multiple myeloma in two years.
And these patients are identified based on various previously published
criteria. Historically, patients were placed on
observation until they developed disease progression, at which point they would be
offered myeloma induction therapy.
In November of 2025, daratumumab, a CD38 monoclonal
antibody, was the first agent approved by the US FDA for treatment for
high-risk smoldering myeloma, and this was based on results from the Phase 3 AQUILA
trial.
In the AQUILA study, patients were randomized to either three years of daratumumab
or active monitoring. And while daratumumab led to an improvement in
progression-free and overall survival in this population,
approximately 40% of patients still progressed at five years despite
early interception with daratumumab, and rates of complete responses were
low at less than 10%.
And this trial is one of many management strategies that have been previously
studied in patients with smoldering myeloma.
Some of these has opted for the goal of disease control with low-intensity
regimens, whereas others have gone for disease eradication with more
high-potency regimens similar to what we give to multiple myeloma patients.
Previous studies with lenalidomide and dexamethasone were also positive compared
to active monitoring in patients with high-risk smoldering myeloma.
And more recently, studies of triplets, quadruplets, and even stem cell
transplantation have been studied in high-risk smoldering myeloma, leading to
deeper responses and higher rates of MRD negative disease.
However, achieving these deep responses unfortunately does not seem to have
correlated with cure, as some of these patients still develop disease
progression many years later.
So we asked the question: Could the use of CAR T-cell therapy in an earlier disease
state lead to disease eradication and the potential of cure at the
time when the immune system is more intact?
And this comes on the heels of the long-term follow-up from the CARTITUDE-1 trial,
in which cilta-cel, a BCMA CAR T-cell therapy, was
administered to heavily pretreated relapse refractory myeloma patients.
And long-term follow-up of this study shows that approximately a third of patients
are still progression free beyond five years, raising the possibility that
this could be curative therapy, at least for a subset of relapse refractory
myeloma patients.
And if you look at the results from the CARTITUDE-4 trial, which looked at
cilta-cel in even earlier disease states in one to three prior lines of
therapy, and in patients that were lenalidomide refractory, this
not only demonstrated improvement compared to standard of care regimens,
but if you look at the Kaplan-Meier curves of survival compared to CARTITUDE-1
study, earlier use of cilta-cel shows even better survival,
suggesting that these therapies may yield even greater benefit if given in earlier
disease states.
So this was the hypothesis of our CAR-PRISM trial.
We asked the question: Could the use of CAR T-cell therapy achieve MRD
negative disease without any induction therapy in these high-risk patients?
Our rationale was that the immune system is less altered in smoldering myeloma,
and CAR T-cell therapy may have potentially even greater benefit compared to
relapse refractory myeloma patients.
We have some preliminary data from the bispecific T-cell engagers also targeting
BCMA with teclistamab and linvoseltamab that have demonstrated high
efficacy also in this population.
In the high-risk smoldering myeloma state, the tumor burden is lower, and the
plasma cells are less genomically complex.
Therefore, we hypothesize that the efficacy may be enhanced and toxicities may
be reduced. And this would allow for lack of exposure
to standard of care induction regimens, which can then be deployed if patients
develop myeloma progression in the future.
And CAR T-cell therapy does have the potential to truly be one and done treatment
for these patients to prevent myeloma in their lifetime.
So here's the study design of the CAR-PRISM trial.
Patients underwent screening and then had T-cell leukapheresis for CAR T-cell
manufacturing.
After this, eligible patients were offered the ability to undergo a stem cell
collection to preserve their ability to have a transplant in the future if they
develop disease progression.
During the time of manufacturing, bridging therapy was not permitted.
And then once the product was ready, patients received standard doses of
lymphodepleting chemotherapy with cyclophosphamide and fludarabine, followed
by a cilta-cel infusion on day one, and then were followed for safety and response
assessments and remain in long-term follow-up.The primary
endpoint of this study was safety, as assessed by incidence of dose-limiting
toxicities, and key secondary endpoints included efficacy
parameters such as overall response rate, complete response rates, MRD
negativity, progression-free survival, and incidence and severity of AEs.
Here's the inclusion criteria for the CAR PRISM trial.
Patients were included if they met high risk criteria per the 20/2/20 model,
defined as the presence of any two of the following parameters.
They could have either an M spike more than two grams per deciliter, a light chain
ratio more than 20, or bone marrow plasmacytosis of more than 20%.
Or they could have the IMWG total risk score of nine or greater using
the scoring system that's outlined on this slide.
We also included patients that met very specific high-risk criteria that have
previously been published,
that included an evolving pattern, an abnormal plasma cell
immunophenotype per the Patema criteria, high-risk cytogenetic
abnormalities based on FISH, and then monoclonal light chain excretion of more than
200 milligrams per 24 hours for those patients that have light chain smoldering
myeloma.
Here's the pertinent exclusion criteria.
So anybody who met criteria for multiple myeloma based on the SLMM-CRAB criteria
were, of course, excluded from this study.
We also opted to exclude patients that had bone marrow plasmacytosis of more than
40%.
This was by design, since this study did not have any induction or bridging
therapy, and this was the first trial looking at CAR T-cell therapy in this disease
state. We wanted to exclude the patients that had high disease burden with the
aim of limiting toxicities in this population.
Here's the patient disposition. So 28 patients were assessed for eligibility.
Twenty-two were approached, and ultimately, 20 patients received CAR T-cell
therapy and remain in follow-up.
And here's the study schema. So this study started initially with a six-patient
safety run-in. We first started to look at a lower cilta-cel
dose of 0.5 CAR T-cells per kilogram.
And first three patients were treated at this dose with staggered enrollment.
After this, there was a pre-planned safety pause and an FDA review, and then
the dose was escalated to the standard dose of cilta-cel of 0.5 to
1 CAR T-cells per kilogram, also with staggered enrollment.
After these first six patients were treated, there was again a pre-planned safety
pause and FDA review, and then the expansion cohort was opened at the
0.5 to 1 CAR T-cell dose per kilogram.
However, during the enrollment of this study, we were also learning in the relapse
refractory myeloma patients that absolute lymphocyte count elevation
can be associated with certain toxicities, in particular neurological toxicities.
So we amended the protocol at this time and implemented an
ALC-triggered prophylactic dexamethasone strategy as we now do for standard
of care patients.
At the same time, we lowered the dose of cilta-cel down to
0.3 CAR T-cells per kilogram to really further optimize the
risk-benefit ratio.
Here are the patient characteristics.
So in total, 20 patients were treated with cilta-cel.
Twelve patients received a lower CAR T-cell dose at 0.3 to 0.5, and eight
patients received more than 0.5 CAR T-cell dose.
The median age was 58. You can see their laboratory parameters.
So median M spike was 1.76 grams per deciliter, a light chain
ratio of near 22, and bone marrow cell plasma infiltration of
20%.
Sixty-five percent of patients met high-risk criteria based on high-risk FISH
abnormalities, and another 65% of patients also met high risk per
the 20/2/20 model.
In terms of screening to apheresis interval, it was 15 days, and
that apheresis to infusion interval was 56 days in this
study.
Here's the overall safety profile.
So no DLTs occurred in the safety run-in cohorts.
CRS occurred in all patients, but no patients had Grade 3 or greater CRS
events. Eighty-five percent of these cases were Grade 1 and 15% were Grade
2. Tocilizumab was administered to 17 patients and
dexamethasone to 13 patients, and this was all done using a low clinical
threshold to prevent higher grade CRS events.
Infectious events were all Grade 1 and 2 with no Grade 3 infections and
mostly involved the upper respiratory tract, and all patients received
IVIG prophylaxis.
In terms of other toxicities, hematologic toxicities were common as expected
with lymphodepleting chemotherapy and CAR T-cells.
Ninety percent of patients had Grade 3 or greater neutropenia, but no incidents of
febrile neutropenia, and all of these incidences resolved.
And 15% of patients had Grade 3 or greater thrombocytopenia, also resolved, and no
patients had any delayed hematologic toxicity.
In terms of other non-heme toxicities, ALT Grade 3 or greater
was increased in two patients in the context of CRS and also ultimately
resolved. And notably, no patients had any evidence of ICANS in this
study. However, we did see non-ICANS neurotoxicity
or NINTs in seven patients, which I'll go over now.
So these events, non-ICANS neurotoxicities, four of
these were cranial nerve palsies, which is a known
side effect of cilta-cel. Four out of these seven resolved completely, and the
median time to onset was 21 days.
Three patients had other ongoing NINTs at the time of data cutoff.
Two of these patients had Grade 1 movement and neurocognitive symptoms.
One of these patients, interestingly, had deposition of phosphorylated
alpha-synuclein on a skin biopsy, suggesting a potential underlying
predisposition to Parkinson's disease.
And one patient had Grade 1 intention tremor during fine motor tasks without
interference in daily living activities.
Here are further details about these three patients.
So all three of these patients experienced robust ALC expansion and
had an elevation in their CD4 to CD8 ratio.
Two out of these three patients received a higher CAR T-cell dose at more than 0.5
CAR T-cells per kilogram, and one patient received a lower dose at 0.3.
All of these patients received high-dose steroids and IVIG for management, and all
three of them have had improvement in their symptoms and currently remain at Grade
1 without interference of daily activities.
One of these patients also received intrathecal chemotherapy, low dose
ruxolitinib, and IV cyclophosphamide, not due to an increase in
severity of symptoms, but really as a strategy to mitigate these
symptoms altogether.So here's the efficacy
data. So at a median follow-up of 15.3 months, all patients achieved MRD
negativity at a sensitivity threshold of 10 to the minus six by next-generation
sequencing, leading to 100% MRD negativity rate.
The median time to MRD negativity was only one month, and all patients had MRD
negativity at 10 to the minus five at one month, and at 10 to the minus six
at two months post-infusion.
MRD negativity was sustained in subsequent assessments in all patients through the
data cutoff.
In terms of IMWG response, all patients achieved an objective response leading to
100% ORR, and 90% of these patients had a complete or
stringent complete response. And in the remaining two patients, the follow-up is
short at approximately 3.5 months, hence immunofixation remains
positive, most likely due to slow clearance of residual paraprotein.
And among 16 patients with at least six months of follow-up, all patients achieve
stringent CR or CR.
And you can see on the swimmer's plot, we have about 12 patients that have crossed
the one-year mark, and all of these continue to have sustained MRD negativity
at that time.
Here is the progression-free survival and overall survival curves.
So there have been no patients that have developed biochemical or
SLIM-CLAP progression to date, and the median PFS and OS has not yet
been reached.
We also looked at some correlative analyses.
So soluble BCMA after CAR T cell infusion declined rapidly,
independent of dose, and fell below the median value of healthy controls by day
21. Interestingly, baseline soluble BCMA did not
correlate with an increased incidence of NINTs because we asked the question, since
these patients did not receive any bridging or induction therapy, whether disease
burden could have played a role in development of these toxicities, and at least
based on the soluble BCMA level, this did not seem to be the case.
Eighteen out of 20 patients had an absolute lymphocyte count of more than 3,000,
and the median peak ALC across the cohort was almost 7,000.
This was higher in patients that had a higher CAR T cell dose and also those that
developed NINTs. I would point out, though, that majority of patients that had a
lower CAR T cell dose also had preemptive dexamethasone that may have curbed
the ALC expansion. And patients who developed NINTs showed greater
post-infusion lymphocyte expansion with higher ALC exposure.
In terms of CAR T cell expansion and subsets, CAR T cell expanded
greater in patients that had a higher CAR T cell dose and also in those patients
that had NINTs.
CD4:CD8 ratio was broadly elevated across this entire study,
did not differ over days 5 to 25 by dose group, but was higher in patients who
developed NINTs compared to those that did not.
And longitudinally, effector memory T cells remained high in the
NINT positive patients, but declined in the low-dose group and
NINT negative groups with reciprocal increases toward more terminally
differentiated memory type states.
So in conclusion, this is the first study of CAR T cell therapy in a precursor
cancer setting where cilta-cel was used as a primary therapy with no
induction or bridging therapy for patients with high-risk smoldering myeloma.
There were no DLTs in the safety run-in cohort, and we saw no high-grade
CRS events, ICHS, CAR T cell enterocolitis, delayed
hematologic toxicities, nor any secondary cancers to date.
Non-ICANS neurotoxicities, a known side effect of cilta-cel,
was observed in seven patients. Four of these resolved completely, and three
patients have mild symptoms with minimal impact on daily activities.
All patients achieved MRD negativity at 10 to the minus six, and to our knowledge,
it is the first time results like this have been seen in any disease
state when it comes to plasma cell disorders.
And MRD negativity remains sustained in all patients.
No patients have progressed to active myeloma with a median of 15.3 months of
follow-up. At the time of peak expansion, we saw mostly CD4
positive CAR T cells, and patients with NINTs showed associations with higher
ALC CAR T cell expansion
with effector memory subtypes and an elevated CD4:CD8 ratio,
with no association with baseline soluble BCMA.
Longer follow-up is needed to determine the durability of response and help inform
the risk-benefit ratio of early use of cilta-cel in this
population.
I'm pleased to share that our paper was just published today in "Nature Medicine,"
and you can use this QR code to access it as it is open access.
Here you'll find a lot more details about patients that were treated on this study.
I want to end by thanking our entire study staff at Dana-Farber Cancer Institute
who worked tirelessly on this study since 2022 when it first
opened. I want to thank our study sponsor, Johnson & Johnson, for supporting this
study. Of course, the patients and their caregivers who really
were phenomenal in enrolling into this trial, first of its kind, and really,
I'm glad to see are benefiting with universal MRD negativity.
I want to thank my co-first author, David Cordus Dos Santos, who was instrumental
in putting the data analysis for this paper together.
And last, but certainly not least, the senior author and my mentor, Irene Ghobrial.
Her pursuit of achieving cure for this disease continues to lead to studies like
this, and I'm forever grateful for working on her team. Thank you.
Thank you very much, Dr. Nadeem. Very interesting
experience with interception.
To discuss this paper is Dr. Krina Patel
from MD Anderson Cancer Center.
Fantastic. Thank you to the chairs for this opportunity and to Dr.
Nadeem for a fantastic trial that I get to now discuss and
explain how I think of the data and how I would use it in my clinic in the
future. So cilta-cel in high-risk smoldering multiple myeloma. Oh.
Okay. I'm left-handed, so I do things backwards, so I apologize.
So again, I think Dr. Nadeem did a great job with some of the introduction of what
smoldering myeloma is. We're one of the few blood cancers,
or any cancer, where we know someone has disease and likely is going to get that
disease in the future, but because there's a huge delay in when they
might get those symptoms, we actually watch patients.
And most of this came from the fact that before, we couldn't really say we could
cure myeloma.Today, we actually had a conference just a month
ago to define what cure in myeloma means because of these novel therapies like
bispecifics and CAR Ts. So I think we have the tools today, but we can
always improve And so really high-risk smoldering myeloma in clinic, and in
my clinic and many others, we don't still treat all patients, all
high-risk smoldering myeloma, but we do actually offer it now.
And there are certain patient populations, I will use things like monoclonal
antibodies, and I'll go over some of those trials that we have.
So really the question comes down to who truly has high-risk smoldering
myeloma? And we're getting better with our clinical tools to define that.
And then how aggressively should we treat those patients? Again, as Dr.
Nadeem said, are we just trying to delay progression to actual myeloma, or are we
trying to cure patients where they never need treatment for myeloma in the future?
So these are our three big studies that we have in smoldering,
historically. So the QREDIC study with len dex
versus observation, the
ECOG-E3A06 len versus observation, and again, the AKILA
study most recently with our first immunotherapy trial, I guess, with
daratumumab versus observation.
And again, we can't really look at observation as a arm anymore if
we were going to do a phase two study with um Celto cell.
So the limitations on the last column for all these studies really are that the
QREDIC study was in pre-modern imaging.
So today we use MRIs to say if patients have lesions in their
bone marrow that we would call it active myeloma.
In the ECOG study, there was no overall survival conclusion.
There was limited follow-up and again, PFS was different, but again, the
population that we called smoldering was very different than what we do today.
And then the AKILA study, again, progression outcomes were really
CRAB criteria. They weren't active myeloma.
So a lot of us, controversy in myeloma is what is active
myeloma? Do we use slim CRAB,
or do we say when patients end up having fractures or renal failure, those are real
clinical outcomes that we want to prevent.
So again, these are just some of the limitations that different folks have made in
the past.
And so again, coming back to who is high risk, I will say the easiest
tool to say someone is high risk is the 20/2/20 model that
Mayo initially started in 2018, and then the
IMWG um validated. It's the easiest because I can do it in
clinic really fast when I have a lot of patients, M protein greater than two, FLC
ratio greater than 20, and bone marrow involvement greater than 20%.
The issue is that in all the studies we had that I just showed historically
didn't use this. And so again, AKILA, the daratumumab study, only
40% of those patients actually would have fit this category of high-risk
smoldering.
So again, um I think our colleagues in the smoldering field have done a great job
of trying to really include all the different parts of why somebody would
relapse within two years or not, or have newly diagnosed myeloma within two
years. But this is what we have. These are all the different iterations of
different classifications for high-risk smoldering.
And so again, in the end, currently, most of us use that last one, which is
the IMWG 2020 with cytogenetic um involvement.
And so um you know again, these are patients who are 44% to 63%
chance of having myeloma at two years.
So again, because of that variation, different patients have different preferences,
and so why most of us don't treat all high-risk patients um as of right
now. So having said that, if someone in front of me
knew that they were about to have myeloma, even if it was going to be five years
from now, but we could say we could cure it, I think that would change that
discussion of risk benefit. And so again, I think durable treatment,
free control is one way to look at um possible cure
and MRD negativity, sustained off therapy.
Haven't yet demonstrated that with any of our prior treatments like lenalidomide or
daratumumab, but here you saw the data and looks pretty fantastic.
Um and also prevention of those clinically meaningful events.
Again, my patients don't get renal failure. They don't get fractures.
They don't get major infections. That is huge for their mortality as well as their
morbidity.
Um and again, we talked about this a little bit, but not all progression events are
equal. And so we know that about 14% to 40% of patients
um only have slim events, and so are we really making a difference when we're
treating patients and intervening um at that smoldering stage?
The other question that comes up is resistance.
When we're treating patients with len or dara, a lot of us think that, well, if
this patient ends up with myeloma in three, four years, can I use my upfront
therapies? Because we usually use a quadruplet, dara, len, bortezomib, dex.
CAR T, we don't use in front line, and resistance mechanisms are very
different. Um we don't think that we have resistance to other therapies, but
again, right now we only do it in really relapsed refractory patients.
So what would happen if we intervened early on and someone does get myeloma, how
am I going to treat that afterwards? So unknown questions.
And then looking at toxicity. So again, with len, grade three, four
non-hematologic toxicities was about 28%.
Many patients came off those studies um because of side effects.
Because again, these patients are asymptomatic.
We're giving them something that causes symptoms, so people do tend to come off
study sometimes. With dara, grade three, four infections were about
16% and 4.6% discontinuation. With
CAR T, we haven't had anyone come off study.
It's a one and done, so it's a little bit harder to say I'm coming off study for
side effects. But you know we heard a little bit about CRS and ICANS.
Those are not things that we worry about so much anymore.
But sometimes things like prolonged cytopenias, other infections long
term, or even risk of IEC colitis, which again, we haven't seen in
studies. This study didn't have it, but in the real world, some of our patients are
getting some of these autoimmune type side effects.
So something that we need to think about as we have more patients
treated.And so, but again, the data's
fantastic. You can't go above 100%, right?
100% overall response rate, flat curves, MRD at 10th and minus
six, which is the best we can do in myeloma right now.
And that PFS and overall just being a straight line.
Again, there's no extra credit. You can't go above 100%.
So this is just phenomenal data, and I think really important for our
field to know that when we go earlier, we can do better for our patients.
And of course, the risk then comes to that toxicity.
The hematologic toxicity in heme, we don't really mind, and most of our patients do
well. Late line, our patients do have significant toxicities where we've had to
give patients stem cells back because of their continued delayed cytopenias.
In early relapse, we don't see that as much, and so I have a feeling that in
smoldering we wouldn't see that either because patients are not as heavily treated.
I think the major toxicity here that we would talk about is that non-ICANS
neurotoxicity. So again, it was
a small number of patients, seven, that had this.
Three of those had cranial nerve palsies, which we do see in patients who get
relapse refractory setting of CAR T, and those are
usually pretty reversible with IVIG and dex.
But when patients have movement disorders, when it affects their
potential in terms of being kind of normal for the rest of their
life, we do worry about that. And that is a big side effect we talk to our
patients. And I think one of the questions that I would have for Dr.
Nadeem is we saw that ALC increase, and we know those are the patients
that are higher likely to get these toxicities.
Do we intervene at that time point? Do we give steroids?
Do we do something to turn that volume down to see if we can improve these
toxicities? Because again, if we didn't have that, I would say this was a
complete home run.
And so coming back, is cure possible before having significant
symptoms from myeloma? This is in patients who had six lines of therapy, so
really relapse refractory. To have 33% being five years
out, and again, the basis of the definition of cure for myeloma
is pretty phenomenal. But I think the question is, are we going to have a
line that goes across the whole 100% for our smoldering patients?
What does that line need to be? And then again, how long do we need it?
Is five years functional cure enough for our smoldering patients, or do we want 10
years to be, or our patients never getting
myeloma as the definition of cure in smoldering myeloma.
So again, we'll finally be able to talk about these things because we have data
like this. And so my last couple of slides, I think the four critical questions
really are, who are the right patients?
Who are those patients that truly are going to have myeloma, that by intervening,
we're actually changing their outcomes? Can we cure them?
Can we have durable control? Are we preventing meaningful
events? And again, is that risk-benefit acceptable for patients who
are smoldering, again, don't have symptoms, otherwise have therapies that could do
really well for a really long time when they get newly diagnosed treatment.
So really that bar has risen. We have to go against things like Len and Dara.
It's not observation anymore, especially in research.
But we really want to make sure that that risk-benefit is really what
is helping our patients in the end. So with that, thank you.
Thanks very much, Dr. Patel. Wonderful discussion.
This paper is now open to questions from the audience.
There's microphones here and a microphone here.
You can also use the online.
James, you want to go first?
So maybe while we're waiting for the audience members to come
up, I thought I would just ask. So given the
very high response rate, 100%, and the toxicity,
could you cut back on the dose even more, or are there other
opportunities to make this even more
palatable?
Yeah, that's a great question.
Cilta-cel, as you know, per... Can you hear
me?
Yeah.
Yeah. So Cilta-cel, as you know, per label, has a dose range that goes from 0.5
to one, and this is compared to a lot of other CAR T-cell
products that have been available.
We hadn't really thought of this one as a clearly dose-dependent-
Right
... CAR T-cell product in the first place.
This was the first trial where we even looked at various dosing strategies, mainly
because of this population. I think what was striking to us is even patients
that had the 0.3 dose, you saw, again, 18 out of 20
patients had an ALC expansion more than 3,000, even with preemptive
dexamethasone. I think what that tells us that this population is just very
different. So the dose intensity, sure has led to reduction in the
CAR T-cell expansion that we have shown, but I don't know if
that's going to ultimately solve the problem here, right?
Because I think it's just so potent, even at a lower dose level, and it's
also hard to know how much lower can you actually go when the dose has already been
reduced so much.
Yeah.
My question, Dr. Nadeem, would be, from the standpoint of
the patients, you've talked to them, you know them, what do they tell you
about whether this therapy was worth it,
tolerable? Would they do it again?
What are the patients telling us about this experience?
So we have had many trials at our center looking at early intervention
type approaches, low intensity therapies, combination therapies, and now
these immune therapies, including trials of bispecific antibodies.
I can tell you that universally, people were lined up for
this trial and continue to knock on our door to see if this trial will be
expanded or there'll be more trials using cellular therapies because they love the
opportunity to be potentially one and done and reduce their risk.
So overall, it has been quite favorable on their part.
Thanks a lot. George, question.
Yeah. George Weiner from University of Iowa. Fantastic data.
Have you thought about backing off on the lymphodepletion?
Yeah, this had come up. Ideally, I think all of us would like to move on
from lymphodepletion across the entire spectrum, and maybe some of the future
technologies like in vivo CARs and others would finally allow us to do that.
It was a 20-patient study. We explored various different doses, but we didn't know
how we would be without lymphodepletion.
But I think it's a very valid question for future studies.
Okay, thanks very much. Wonderful presentation and discussion, and
congratulations on the paper in "Nature Medicine," which is out right now, I
believe. So we can learn more details there.
Thank you.
So up next we have Janos Tanyi from University of
Pennsylvania, who's going to be talking about a
first-in-human KIR CAR in
mesothelin expressing tumors.
Janos?
Good morning, ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you very much for the ACR program committee to allow me to present
this very early data. And I am from University of Pennsylvania, and
I will talk about this initial results of the first-in-human dose-escalation
study of a multi chain killer immunoglobulin-like receptor, CAR,
against mesothelin overexpressing solid tumors.
Here you can see my disclosure information.
So historically, we know that
traditional single chain chimeric antigen receptor, genetically
engineered T cells, has a beautiful clinical activity against hematologic
malignancies. But unfortunately, with a few exceptions, we didn't
see the same clinical efficacy against solid tumors.
But we have seen a lots of on-target, off-tumor toxicities,
such as CRS and ICANS. For example, one of my
earlier SS1 directed, not fully humanized single-chain
CAR showed a short-term, about four weeks of tumor shrinking
activity without major side effect.
But when I changed this for a fully humanized
single-chain fragment variable, unfortunately, it failed to show
clinical efficacy, but associated with horrible
unacceptable toxicities. In all naturally
occurring immune cells, like B lymphocytes, T lymphocytes, natural
killer cells, they function through a
paired receptor system where the extracellular target
binding domain is completely separate from the intracellular
costimulatory domain. Meanwhile, in the traditional single-chain
CARs, we see that the extracellular target binding domain fused together with the
costimulatory domain, which results with a low but
constant signaling of the CAR T cells, ending with an early T
cell exhaustion. So our new multi-chain killer
immunoglobulin-like receptor, CAR T cell derived from natural killer cells.
The extracellular target binding domain, the KIR2DS2,
armed with SS1 single-chain fragment variable, is completely
separate from the DAP12 intracellular costimulatory domain.
But when the target cell shows up and antigen binding happen, the two
domain fuse together and the T cell get activated, lyse the
target cells, and when the antigen dilation happened,
the two motifs separates again and the T cell rests.
With this, the splitting receptor design
provided a natural on and off switch mechanism for
this particular T cell. In our early preclinical
experiments, we
transduced T cells with lentiviral vectors containing
the traditional single chain CAR41BB
CD3 zeta anti-mesothelin CAR or our
new multi-chain CAR, and we compare this to untransduced T
cells. As you see here, we
stained the particular CAR T cell after transduction with differentiation
markers such as CCR7 and CD45RA for
phenotyping. The basic phenotype of the untransduced T cells and the
multi-chain KIR CAR stayed similar and differed
substantially from the single-chain CAR, which showed a high
expansion of central memory and naive T cells.
As you see under figure A, the untransduced T cells and the multi-chain
CAR showed a low CCR7, but high TAM and TIM-3
effector T cell expansion, and even differentiation,
the multi-chain KIR CAR retained all four differentiation
phenotypes. After transduction, when the T cell
should rest, as you see on figure B and C, the
single-chain CAR still expressed a high level of activation markers,
4-1BB, and a high level of exhaustion markers, PD-1
and TIM3,
which activity you didn't see with the multi-chain CAR.
On this figure, you see a flow cytometric figure of the T cell
proliferation when the CAR T cells culture together
with mesothelin overexpressing or mesothelin non-expressing target cells.
As you see here that both T cell product shows a high T cell
proliferation when co-cultured together with mesothelin expressing target cells,
but you don't see this activity in the multi-chain KIR
CAR where it's co-cultured together with the mesothelin negative target cells.
But you see that the traditional single-chain CAR still shows a T cell
proliferation. On figure B, you see the quantitative summary of the T
cell proliferation when it's co-cultured together with mesothelin
negative or mesothelin positive target cell.
The secretory cytokines such as interferon gamma, tumor necrosis factor
alpha, and interleukin 2 was measured in the medium overnight with a
mesoscale display assay. And as you see here, when co-cultured together
with mesothelin positive target cell, both T cell product shows a nice
effector cytokine production. Meanwhile, when co-cultured together
with mesothelin negative target cells, only the single chain
traditional CAR shows mesothelin effector
cytokine expression. These figures and experience clearly shows
when we replace the unnatural single-chain
CAR-T design for a more natural split receptor design,
we can completely eliminate this low tonic signaling of the CAR T
cells.Here in this incicide cytotoxicity assay, you
see the cytotoxic activity of the CAR T-cells when co-cultured
together with mesothelin expressing, Figure A, or
mesothelin non-expressing, Figure C, target cells.
As you see with the red line, the multi-chain Kir CAR immediately
significantly lyses the target cells.
Meanwhile, the blue line, the traditional single-chain CAR
lyses less effectively the target cells.
And this cytotoxic activity started with an 18 to 20 hours
delay. With the black line, the untransduced T-cells did not lyse any
target cells.
When it's co-cultured together with mesothelin non-expressing target cells, the
red and the
black line stay together, which means the untransduced T-cells and the multi-chain
Kir CAR did not lyse any mesothelin non-expressing target cells.
Meanwhile, the single-chain CAR started to lyse some of the target
cells with a 40 hours delay of onset.
In vivo, we injected mesothelin overexpressing human
epithelioid mesothelioma tumor cell lines in the flank
skin of immunosuppressed mice in the xenograft model.
And when the tumor was measurable, we infused the mice with a different CAR T
product. And as you see on Figure B with the red line, the
multi-chain CAR is significantly decreased and
many times eliminated the flank tumor from the mice.
Meanwhile, you didn't see the same clinical activity with the blue line with
the single-chain CAR. Figure C, you see the area under the
curve of the tumor volume after the T-cell treatment in the mice,
and Figure D you see the concentration of the CAR
T-cells in the peripheral blood of the mice in day 20.
As you see here with the red column, significantly less number of
multi-chain CAR is present in the peripheral blood than a single-chain CAR.
Also, we evaluated the interferon gamma levels at day 13 and 20,
and you see that the multi-chain CAR shows a high effect or
cytokine expression at day 13, which decreases down when the work is done.
But the single-chain CAR shows very low expression which
increased on day 20, even in the absence of clinical
activity.
Based on this, we designed the first-in-human Phase I, three by three
dose-escalation study of the multi-chain killer immune
globulin-like receptor CAR T-cells against mesothelin
overexpressing malignancies. The primary objective was to evaluate
the safety and the feasibility of this CAR product.
Secondary objective was to evaluate the expansion and the persistence of the CAR
T-cell in the peripheral blood, evaluate the cytokine serum
levels, and of course, some clinical activity by RECIST criteria.
The study design was very simple. After enrollment, leukapheresis,
and CAR T-cell production, the patient received a lymphodepleting
chemotherapy with fludarabine and cyclophosphamide, and three days later, the
patient received a single IV
infusion of multi-chain Kir CAR, and we followed the patient up to
progression or up to 12 months. We planned to do
six dose levels, each single dose level referred elevation of the
previous dose level. We started with a very low dose, one
times 10 on the seven CAR T-cell per meter squared, and we planned to
finish on three times 10 on the nine CAR T per meter squared.
Today, I will talk about the outcomes of the first three dose
levels.
We enrolled patients with a histologically proven primary peritoneal, fallopian
tube, ovarian cancer, cholangiocarcinoma, or
malignant epithelioid mesothelioma who already received at least
one prior line of standard of care treatment.
The patient needs to be older than 18 years of age and
had to have an ECOG Zero to 1 functional status and at least one
measurable target lesion by RECIST criteria.
We excluded patients with biphasic or sarcomatoid
mesotheliomas or if the patient has an untreated secondary malignancy.
We also excluded patients with a history of B-cell lymphoma, T-cell lymphoma,
prior CAR T therapy,
any active infection, or any active autoimmune
disease. In the first three dose levels, we enrolled nine patients,
and surprisingly, no dose-limiting toxicity was seen in the first
three dose level. The average age of the patient was 55 years of
age, and it was a heavily pretreated patient population with an average of four
prior line of standard of care treatment.
We enrolled five ovarian, three mesothelioma, and one cholangiocarcinoma patient.
Here you see the adverse event profile of the first nine patients.
The CAR tox toxicity was evaluated using the ASTCT
guidelines. Meanwhile, the other toxicity was evaluated with the
CTC AE version five. As you see here, only
three cytokine release syndrome was seen and two
Grade 1 and one Grade 2. No ICANS was seen in this study
population, and only one patient experienced multiple Grade 4
toxicities after fludarabine infusion but before CAR-T infusion, which
was associated with fludarabine.
It was neurotoxicities, cortical blindness, and
cytopenias. The most frequently seen adverse events were
cytopenias after lymphodepleting chemotherapy.
Here you see the pharmacokinetics of the CAR T-cells.
The persistence and expansion of the CAR T-cells in the peripheral
blood was evaluated using GenomiQ PCR.
And as you see here, within each single dose level, the peak expansion of the CAR
T-cells was very similar amongst the patients.
But when we increased dose level one to dose level two,
the increase in the peak expansion was not directly proportional with the dose
level increase. As we increased only three times of the dose,
the peak expansion increased with 24.
The persistence of the CAR T-cells was lined up with our prior
SS-1 experience. We were able to identify the presence of the CAR
T-cells up to 28 days in the peripheral blood of the patients,
and even a little bit longer in ascites.
Here you see in the pharmacodynamics of the CAR T-cells, notably we have
three patients with low-grade cytokine release syndrome.
And as you see on Figure A, the peak level of interferon gamma and tumor
necrosis factor-alpha was not correlating with the presence or absence of
cytokine release syndrome. As you see in Figure B, we
cumulatively measure the nine-patient tumor necrosis factor-alpha and
interferon gamma levels with the Luminex assay.
And after T-cell infusion, you see that these effector cytokines are
increasing, which showing good biological activity of the
T-cellsBut this increase is mild and never
exceeded 120 picogram per milliliter.
On Figure C, you see that three of the patients had
very high interleukin-6 levels in the 1,000 picogram per milliliter.
Only two of those showed the sign of cytokine release syndrome.
Here you see the clinical responses with the dose level
one is green, with dose level two is blue, and the
dose level three, the highest dose, is orange.
Under A, the upper plot, you see the total
sum of tumor volume responses in the three cohort.
On Figure B, you see the waterfall plot, the best overall response measured at one
imaging time point after T cell infusion.
And Figure C, you see the individual target
lesion volume changes in the three cohort.
If you focus on dose level three, you see that when we
increase the dose level, the tumor volume showed a
downtrending tendency.
Here you see two representative examples of the responses.
On the left side, Figure A, you see a 50-year-old female
patient with stage four mesothelioma after
five prior line of treatment. By RECIST criteria,
the patient showed a partial response at day 28, which is still ongoing many
months later. On Figure B, you see a 54-year-old
female patient with stage 4B high-grade serous ovarian cancer with three prior
lines of standard of care treatment.
The patient at day 28 showed a tumor shrinkage, but
inside of the stable disease category, we slowly grow back to the original
starting level on month three. Here you see the swimmer plot
of the individual patients' responses by duration of response from the
shortest to the longest from top to bottom.
On the left side, you clearly see the dose level number and
the bar color showing the tumor type.
Gray is cholangiocarcinoma,
light blue is ovarian cancer, dark blue is mesothelioma.
As you see here, as we increase the dose, not just the peak expansion
increased, but it's increased the disease stabilization rate, increased the
duration of response. In cohort number one, from the three patients, we have one
stable disease. Cohort number two from the three patients, two stable disease.
And the dose level three, the first objective response, partial response, and a
stable disease. Altogether, the disease stabilization rate was
55%, even in these low early doses.
So as a summary, I can state that the multi-chain killer immunoglobulin-like
receptor CAR is safe and feasible.
In these first three dose levels, no dose-limiting toxicity was
seen. Only three low-grade CRS was seen, and no
ICANS was seen in this particular patient population.
With the dose increase, we see the increase in the peak exposure of
the CAR T cells, increase of the disease stabilization rate, and increase of the
duration of response. The elevating interferon gamma
tumor necrosis factor-alpha levels clearly shows a good biological
activity of this new CAR T-cell design without on-target
off-tumor toxicity. The enrollment of dose level four,
five, six and identifying the recommended phase two dose and the maximum
tolerated dose is still ongoing. I would like to say thank
you for all the patients and the supportive families who were enrolled in this
particular trial, and of course, all the scientists, researchers, study
coordinators, and investigators who contributed to this very
early work. Thank you very much for your attention.
Thank you so much, Dr. Tami. That was very interesting.
And now to discuss this is Dr. Sandip Praveen Patel
from US-- UCSD rather.
Dr. Praveen. Yeah.
Thank you for the opportunity to discuss this very interesting and important
clinical abstract.
My talk is titled "Avoiding Cellular Burnout: Enhancing Activity of CAR T Cells in
Solid Tumors."
These are my disclosures.
Historically, we've used single-chain CAR T constructs in the
treatment of both hematological as well as investigation of solid tumor
malignancies. These historically have involved a single
chain that has been transfected either by lentiviral or
bead-based methods to ensure optimal signaling and the
creation of a chimeric product that lyses tumor-specific
cells. Now, when this happens, there's tonic signaling, and
oftentimes in solid tumors, we can actually create the very problem we're trying to
avoid in terms of either activation-induced cell death or T cell
anergy. And so the idea behind the study that we
just heard about involves the use of multi-chain KIR CARs, as shown
here. And this recapitulates more natural signaling
and the way T cell receptors are designed in terms of
antigen-specific responses. So here you get initial binding of the
antigen to the
variable chain, and then endogenous signaling that's separated.
So this leads to separation of target binding as well as T cell
signaling activation and a more natural T cell tonicity that
can potentially result in reduced activation-induced cell
death.
And so with these natural rest and recovery cycles, you only get activation
of the meso product we heard about under the context of tumor
engagement with the mesothelin protein.
And theoretically, this can minimize activation-induced anergy from chronic
stimulation, which is often a problem in many of the solid tumors mentioned,
including mesothelioma.
And so there may be other virtues in this type of construct
above and beyond more natural tonic signaling.
We see here as nicely summarized, a higher
potency of activity against a mesothelin-expressing cell
line on your left, and interestingly, less
self-reactive
activity relative to the single-chain CAR construct.
And so you enhance that therapeutic index for maximizing
efficacy and trying to minimize toxicity in terms of normal
protein binding and mesothelin.And so in the STAR101 study
that you just heard about, these are patients with refractory ovarian tumors,
epithelial mesothelioma, and cholangiocarcinoma.
And as much as we talked about the cell dose for the data presented, one
times ten to the eighth cells per meter squared, one important thing to consider,
especially in solid tumor patients, is the lymphodepletion paradigm.
Here, fludarabine 30 milligrams per meter squared for four days,
cyclophosphamide 300 milligrams per meter squared for three days.
There are the 3300 lower dose lymphodepletion regimen.
However, for many patients, this can represent a substantial toxicity
in terms of nausea, vomiting, and cytopenias.
And given, for example, that the median age of diagnosis for mesothelioma
is 72, the hematologic consequences of this dosing
schema, especially when we've utilized these in younger patients, is something to
consider. The second aspect of this that's important
is that the period between leukapheresis and manufacture is key.
As we saw just earlier for the novel cellular therapy product in
smoldering myeloma, the manufacturing time is key.
However, in solid tumors, this is equally important, as patients often will need
bridging therapy. And so something to think about as we're looking at the context
of the study and the type of patient that received their SynCure
110 mesothelin KIR CAR infusion.
And so Phase 1 historically has been looked at as a way of
investigating not only feasibility but safety, but increasingly, and
especially for cellular therapy products, understanding efficacy is
key. And so when we look at the swimmer plot here, we see that the patient with
the durable remission had mesothelioma.
Now, this is very interesting in and of itself.
One of the salient aspects with cellular immunotherapy, as you just heard about in
the earlier session for smoldering myeloma, is the ability for a single treatment
paradigm to lead to durable responses.
And so for this patient, who now, almost three months after
their infusion with mesothelioma, not only has a remission, but a
sustained remission, I think is very important.
And so what do we learn from each patient in this Phase 1
trial? What are some aspects that we can take in terms of thinking about which
types of patients could we preferentially enrich for, either by biomarker,
histology, or other parameters? Well, one for mesothelioma, these are
patients with epithelioid mesothelioma.
These are tumors that historically have high protein level expression of
mesothelin. So could there be a correlate of target in terms of
those patients that can respond to treatment?
Secondly, even with epithelial mesothelioma, there are various genetic factors
that can lead to the development of that tumor type.
For example, germline predilection or SMARCA mutation in the BAP1
gene, asbestos-related or smoking-related exposure, which can lead to a more
interferon-rich environment for which the cell therapy may be more
efficacious. And then secondly, prior IO response.
These are often patients treated with anti-CTLA-4 or anti-PD-1-directed
therapies. Did antecedent immune checkpoint blockade therapy
have a potential virtuous effect in terms of enhancing efficacy for this
patient?
And so "energy and persistence conquer all things" is a famous quote by Ben
Franklin. And so let's dive into some of the data that's hugely important
to try to understand which patients may benefit.
So when we look at the one responder you see here denoted in red, patient
003004, this patient had Grade
1/Grade 2 cytokine release syndrome.
And when you look at the overall cohort in terms of persistence
of cells after lymphodepletion, this patient had the highest
persistence as denoted in the triangle on the far right.
And so do we need low-grade cytokine release syndrome to facilitate
CAR T cell persistence in solid tumors? Is this actually virtuous?
Clearly, we don't want higher grade events, which may be toxic and dangerous to our
patients, but does low-grade cytokine release facilitate better engraftment of
the cell product is one important question.
And so related to cellular persistence, is this a cause or an effect
relative to an effective cellular therapy product?
While we saw here the persistence of CAR Ts associated with clinical response,
is this really just a form of survivorship bias?
And fundamentally, you need that initial antitumor response for cellular
persistence to have any meaning and to create a memory T cell that'll likely lead
to durable remissions, which is the goal for these patients.
Additionally, as this drug continues development, does one
consider adding PD-1 checkpoint blockade agent, for example, to
minimize the risk of anergy, as well as other types of
therapeutics that may be needed to ensure that these cells optimally function and
continue to kill the tumor? But fundamentally, this has been a unique challenge in
solid tumors. And so when we think about mesothelin-directed approaches,
on-target, off-tumor toxicities has historically been a barrier with
low-level mesothelin expression in the heart, lung, and stomach.
Mesothelin is a glycoprotein that can be expressed on these as well as other
organs. Expression can be inducible, especially under
cellular stress of normal tissue.
And normal tissue expression of the target has been a key issue for many
solid tumor CAR T cell targets. And so I congratulate the investigators on
pursuing this novel strategy.
One example of this is pulmonary toxicity.
And so we see here with an older cell product, not the one we're discussing today,
that high-dose mesothelin-targeting CAR T cells actually bound
low-level mesothelin expression in the pulmonary parenchyma.
And this can occur under, for example, infectious conditions, inflammatory
conditions, for example, pneumonia.
And so we can, in fact, lead to expression of a target you
otherwise wouldn't expect at baseline and develop toxicity.
And so finding specific cellular strategies that minimize
these off-target toxicities is key.
Other challenges in CAR T in solid tumors is target selection.
We had a very nice talk about multiple myeloma, and we can ablate
CD19 and BCMA fully with both tumor as well
as normal B-cell ablation with supportive care with antibiotics,
vaccination strategies, IVIG, for example.
But mitigating these acute SCRS and ICANS-type toxicities,
as well as these chronic toxicities, is feasible in this tumor type.
However, for solid tumor antigens, we've not yet been able to completely
ablate normal cells safely due to the nature of the protein being
targeted.And so there are several challenges we have that we're trying to
overcome in solid tumor cell therapy, and I want to congratulate the study team on
addressing many of these. The first is target selection.
We want to find a target that's preferentially expressed on tumor cells to maximize
efficacy, but you want to minimize expression, including inducible expression
on critical cell organ cells to maximize safety.
Secondarily, cellular optimization ensure an optimal delivery of the cell
into the tumor microenvironment, getting to where it needs to be to elicit its
effect, and then being able to move on and exert a systemic effect in developing
a memory is very important. And thinking about those post-infusion
strategies in addition to the lymphodepletion paradigm is important for us to
ensure that these therapies maximize their benefit in terms of long-term
persistence of effective cell therapy.
Other cellular therapy strategies that are being investigated including logic
gating to maximize safety and using AND/OR gates to
protect normal epithelia, suicide switches for those patients in whom cell
therapy may have led to a high-grade event that needs immediate termination, and a
natural signaling as we discussed here, which recapitulates a more
endogenous activation of the T cell to
maximize anti-tumor effect without leading to anergy.
And then finally, and potentially most importantly, thinking about the logistical
complexity of these cellular therapies.
There are many unstable bridges in solid tumors compared to other hematologic
malignancy states where you need bridging chemotherapy and effective bridging
chemotherapy to make sure that that product that you're generating actually makes
it to benefit that patient, and then the ability to create these products at scale,
thinking about off-the-shelf strategies, given the number of patients with these
diseases. But with that, I'd like to think
about the future directions of CAR T in the hematologic malignancies as a model
for solid tumors, think about novel cellular engineering strategies for
these tumors, think about the toxicities for these patient populations.
We have three different cohorts, different median ages.
And then thinking about how these cellular therapies can potentially address unmet
needs for immunologically cold tumors.
And with that, I'd like to thank the study team and most importantly the patients
for their wonderful work on advancing the field forward for our patients.
Thank you, Dr. Patel, for the very
clear
discussion of this. Please, microphone number one.
Hi. Really nice data. Thank you. I was curious, I have two questions.
One of them is DAP12 only has one ITAM, so it's not a perfect
comparison with the three ITAMs in CD3 zeta.
I'm wondering if you compared it to, say, a CD3 zeta with
two mutated
1xx ITAMs, for example.
And what is the contribution of the physical separation of the CAR
versus just the differences in the ITAM domains themselves?
First question.
So
I just can talk about the basic science experiments which were
done previously at UPenn comparing the CD3 zeta
CAR for the DAP12 efficacy. I was not part
of that work, but they found about same clinical efficacy and
same
activation, so they were not different.
The second question was-
Sorry, second question is still coming.
But the ITAM, so the DAP12
doesn't provide any costimulatory signaling.
So I'm wondering if there's any way to engineer in costimulation since that seems
to be a critical component of CAR T cell.
I'm sure there is.
Again, I'm a clinician, so I didn't do that particular basic design,
but
we will investigate this question.
Other questions? Did you have a follow-up question?
No.
Okay. And I may have
missed this because it's a little bit of an echo in here.
I just wanted to ask about if there was
any
plural symptoms that would suggest on-target
off-tumor
toxicity.
With my prior single-chain CARs, we have plenty of
mesothelin targeting. The difference was that this is an
SS1 single-chain fragment variable with a medium
avidity, which is not address and target as much low
mesothelin expression. My prior fully humanized
single-chain CAR T cells with a higher avidity and higher activity
targeted immediately as the first pass effect in the lung, the type pneumocytes
and
mesothelin layers, pericardium, peritoneum
were targeted, and there were side effects.
Now, in this particular design, number one,
the effector cytokine expression is much lower and much
shorter. So that particular
stimulation of any cytokine-related problem is
significantly less, and also we choose this
particular single-chain fragment variable to avoid those side
effects which caused by other single-chain fragment variables.
Fantastic.
Thank you so much. If there's no additional questions, then we want to
thank you so much for this presentation.
So for our third presentation, I'd like to introduce Dr.
Ignacio Melero from the University Clinic of
Navarro in Pamplona, Spain, and the University of Oxford,
UK. He will discuss experience with the FAP-targeted
4-1BB ligand trimeric costimulation.
Thank you very much, Robert, and congratulations on becoming president.
Thank you.
So it's my pleasure to present to you on behalf of
co-investigator
our clinical trial, our abstract entitled
Fibroblast activation protein-targeted 4-1BB ligand
trimeric stimulation amplifies T cell activation
and antitumor efficacy of a
CA-directed T cell engager in
microsatellite stable colorectal cancer.
These are my disclosures.
Metastatic colorectal cancer keeps being a very
much unmet medical need, and it's the
second cause of cancer-related mortality
worldwide.
So once patients progress to the first and
second-line
therapies,
the overall response rate and progression-free survival achieved by
the best approved treatment, including
TAS-102 and bevacizumab,
is fairly poor.
PD-L1/PD-1 checkpoint inhibitors
are effective in patients with metastatic colon cancer
suffering microsatellite unstable disease,
but largely ineffective in patients with
MSS
metastatic colorectal cancer,
especially those with liver metastasis.
Civisatuximab is a CA-targeted T cell
engager by a specific antibody that has shown
signs of clinical activity in MSS
metastatic colorectal cancer.
A very important concept is that to achieve full T cell
activation and expansion and acquisition of effector functions,
there is the need for integration of signalings from the T cell receptor
CD3 complex, a costimulatory molecules
or accessory pathways of activation.
And 4-1BB is a bona fide costimulatory
molecule that happens to appear on the surface of T cells
following T cell activation by antigen recognition or
treatment with T cell engagers.
FAP4-1BB ligand is a fibroblast
activation protein-targeted 4-1BB ligand that
acts as an agonist contingent on engagement on
FAP on fibroblasts present in the
tissue.
So in a first-in-human phase one clinical trial,
dose escalation of FAP4-1BB ligand monotherapy was associated
with very acceptable safety, increase
intratumoral T cell infiltration, and modest signs of
clinical activity. And what we report here are the
results of a phase 1b study that
evaluated the combination of civisatumab given every three weeks
with escalating doses of FAP4-1BB ligand
given every week or in a three-week
intervals in part one and part two to patients
with microsatellite stable
metastatic colorectal cancer.
This study owes a lot to the group of Pablo Mana, who
generated two very interesting constructs.
Civisatumab is a T cell engager engaging
CD3 epsilon with bivalent arms
binding to Siglec-V,
but to an epitope of Siglec-V that is only
present in the membrane-bound form of Siglec-V
but not in the soluble circulating CA
with an FC inert region.
FAP4-1BB ligand is a construct also based in
immunoglobulin scaffold with a silent FC version, and there
is an arm that binds with high affinity to
fibroblast activation protein, and then it's engineered to
have a trimeric form of the natural ligand
4-1BB/4-1BB ligand.
And the concept is that
in the presence of the T cell engager
that signals through the CD3 TCR complex,
4-1BB becomes expressed on the plasma membrane and
thereby is amenable to costimulation by
FAP4-1BB ligand once and only
once it is targeted to the fibroblast to mediate
cross-linking.
This group was able to make the proof of concept
that such a combination could work in humanized mouse
models with CD34
human stem cells and xenografted with
colon carcinoma tumors and a fibroblast of human
origin. And what was very clear is that there was synergy
and was associated to expansion of CTLs and
differentiation to TH1 phenotype in the CD4 compartment.
The study addressed the safety,
maximal tolerated dose, pharmacokinetics,
pharmacodynamic activity, and was searching for
signs of preliminary activity.
And it was designed in such a manner that patients received cycles
of civisatumab together and with
a sequential FAP4-1BB ligand at
escalating doses. Importantly, all
patients received pretreatment, a dose of
obinutuzumab, the afucosylated
glycoengineered CD20 antibody to deplete B
cells, since civisatumab almost
constantly induce antidrug
antibodies.
Those reductions were permitted as we were
thinking about potential cytokine release
syndromesThe population in the study
had a total of 52 patients suffering
metastatic colorectal cancer.
Many of them had liver metastasis, 66% and
81 in each of the arms. Lung disease was
present in 46% and 54%
of the patients, as well as peritoneal
involvement in some of them.
They had to receive two prior lines of therapy, and the
median prior therapy was
three lines.
Patients, according to guidelines, would have received previous exposure to
monoclonal antibodies directed to VEGF or EGFR, as
indicated, and only two of them had received
checkpoint inhibitors in the context of clinical trials.
From the point of view of safety, there were
signs of GI toxicity expected for the
civisatuximab in monotherapy that included
nausea and diarrhea in 55% of
the patients treated. Four patients had
grade five adverse events, two of them considered
related. One of them was a rapid general physical deterioration of the patient
and the other one a cytomegalovirus-associated
colitis.
Cytokine release syndrome occurred in 57% of the patients.
It was typically grade one and grade two,
in some cases required dose reduction in subsequent cycles,
and there were two cases of grade three.
But the safety profile of the combination was considered
manageable at the tested doses.
Analyzing sequential serum samples
of the patients, we could detect increases in interferon gamma, soluble
CD25, and IL-6, denoting T cell activation.
And when we compare that with samples drawn in a clinical trial
testing civisatuximab monotherapy, such increases were of
a higher or a larger magnitude. In peripheral blood,
we could also see evidence for activation of CD8 T cells
and CD4 T cells that were co-expressing the
Ki67 proliferation marker, as well
as for the expansion of different subsets of memory
CD8 T cells.
Analyzing sequential biopsies taken from the patients
pre-treatment and on treatment, we could see clear increases of CD8 T
cell density in the tumors,
that some of them were co-expressing Ki67 indicating
activation, and that was of a larger magnitude to what
had been observed up in the trial of monotherapy
of civisatuximab. That was a separate prior clinical
trial done by the same teams.
Observing pair biopsies, it became clear that there was
a very prominent pattern of T cell infiltration in the
fibrotic tracts of the tumors, although there was also
infiltration in the malignant glands.
As a result of that, we were treating many tumors that were
phenotypically classified as immune deserts, and many of
them were transformed into T cell inflamed tumors,
but also having this kind of excluded phenotype in
which the T cells are mainly concentrated in the fibrotic tracts
where you expect the fibroblasts to express FAP.
From the point of view of clinical activities, there
were confirmed partial responses that occurred
across all the FAP-4-1BB ligand tested
levels.
There were patients with liver metastases who
experienced partial responses, five out of nine
cases, and considering confirmed PR in subsequent CT
scans, four out of seven had these
liver metastases. The confirmed overall response
rate across cohorts in this study is
13%,
and if considering the highest levels of 4-1BB ligand
doses, it would be 20%. And this
compares favorably to what had been observed in the
prior trial with civisatuximab monotherapy,
especially considering disease control rate
that in our trial was at 50%.
There was evidence of stabilization and tumor shrinkage, and we
tried to correlate this with several parameters, including
CEA expression in the tumor, including FAP presence
on fibroblasts in the tumor, and CD8
infiltration. There was a tendency for more tumor
shrinkage in tumors with higher levels of CEA
and of FAP and some tendency for the brain
filtration by CD8 T cells.
Lower tumor burden was also associated to
more responses, although with this number of patients, there are
tendencies, but not really a statistical
meaningful evidence.
So to summarize, there are several
limitations in the interpretation of this data that we must
acknowledge. This is a phase one dose escalation clinical
trial with a small cohort of patients.
We were doing some comparisons across studies that,
although done by the same sponsor and by the same teams,
are always riskful to fully interpretate.
And what is very important is that to the best of our knowledge, this is the first
clinical study investigating coordinated signal one and signal
two co-stimulation in the activation of T cells in
patients with predominantly non-inflamed solid
tumors.Microsatellite
stable
metastatic colorectal patients who were included in the trial had
exhausted all the standard care of treatment options.
And in these patients, the combination was
considered to have a manageable safety profile.
The observations on safety, pharmacodynamic, and efficacy data are
consistent with the mode of action proposed for the
combination that has been seen clinically to
be synergistic. And importantly, we are
making use with a T-cell engager of a 4-1BB
agonist for stimulation.
Our data warrant further investigations combining
4-1BB agonists, for example, FAP4-1BB
ligand or others that are with T-cell engagers to
improve activity.
We are very grateful to patients, their families, and caregivers, to the
Roche study team, especially Axel Boenke, Tamara Tanos,
Pablo Umaña, Christian Klein, and their teams, as
well as co-investigators in the clinical trial.
And now, this will be accessible
using this QR and with all the details of the clinical trial
in a just appeared publication in "Nature Medicine".
Thank you very much for your attention.
Thanks very much.
To discuss this paper now will be Dr. Anthony L.
Kouhari from USC Norris Comprehensive Cancer Center in
Los Angeles.
Good morning. Thank you for the organizing committee and the session co-chairs
for the invitation to discuss this important abstract, and
congratulations to Dr. Melero and his colleagues on an excellent
study and presentation.
Here are my disclosures.
To put this in context, it is important to note that MSS
colorectal cancer is a cold tumor characterized by an
immunosuppressive tumor microenvironment
due to a multitude of factors, including genomic alterations,
different levels of immunosuppressive cells, some stromal
changes,
as well as other immunosuppressive tumor microenvironment factors.
In this context, single-agent checkpoint inhibitors that target
PD-1 or PD-L1 have no activity.
Limited activity is noted when we combine
anti-PD-1 antibodies with first-generation
CTLA-4 antibodies. So this is
definitely an area of unmet need.
One of the major strengths of the presentation by Dr.
Melero is the outstanding scientific rationale.
So, bispecific T-cell engagers have had limited
success in solid tumors, and this is due to a multitude
of reasons, some of which are listed here: low and
heterogeneous antigen expression, limited tumor
accessibility, and low levels of T-cell infiltration in
the tumor microenvironment.
The combination studied in this trial does tackle some
of these limitations.
So sibicetumab, as a bispecific T-cell engager, delivers the
first activation signal of the T-cells, but that is not
sufficient in the suppressed tumor microenvironment
of MSS colorectal cancer.
So this is where the second co-stimulation signal from
the FAP4-1BB ligand fusion protein
becomes critically important in enhancing T-cell proliferation.
The idea of using 4-1BB agonistic activity has
been already
evaluated in the CAR T setting.
Another important factor to note is that the conditional
activation of 4-1BB that requires co-binding
to FAP is important in reducing
toxicity that has historically been seen to the
systemic exposure to monoclonal antibodies targeting
4-1BB.
Dr. Melero and his colleagues had shown previously that the
combination had resulted in superior antitumor
activity in preclinical models and did increase CD8
T-cell infiltration in tumors.
To the right, in organoid models, they had shown also that
the combination results in higher interferon gamma secretion,
as well as increased tumor cell killing in both CEA
high and CEA low colon cancer organoids.
Now, moving to the clinical trial results.
The biomarker results from this study are consistent with the
preclinical hypothesis. So in the periphery, we see
signs of immune stimulation that are superior with this
combination compared to monotherapy.
So see higher interferon gamma and more sustained soluble
CD25 increases.
In tumor biopsies, there is a significant increase in
proliferating CD8 T-cells with the combination
compared to monotherapy. Of course, Dr.
Melero already mentioned the limitation of cross-study comparisons since the
monotherapy samples come from a different trial.
One of the caveats I have is that these changes still do not
represent a predictive biomarker, and these pharmacodynamic
changes do not have a clear association with
antitumor activity at this point.
In regards to safety,
the combination resulted in mostly low-grade adverse events
as shown here, and the CRS events were mostly low
grade. So my conclusion here is that the combination is feasible
with a manageable safety profile.It is unclear, however,
if the adverse events differ by dose and by schedule.
So
focusing a little bit more on the dosing and schedule issue.
Finding the optimal dose for cell engagers in solid tumors is certainly
challenging,
and it is certainly different than what we see with cytotoxic
therapy. So the optimal dose is not necessarily the MTD.
So cibersertib monotherapy had an MTD of 400 milligrams once
weekly or once every three weeks.
The dose of 100 milligrams that is used in this study
is based on empiric observations from a different trial in
combination with atezolizumab, where the 100 milligram
dose had the best balance of safety and efficacy.
However, this doesn't mean this is the optimal dose to combine with
the FAP41BB ligand fusion protein.
Before I talk about antitumor activity, I just want to remind us of the
current landscape of approved regimens for MSS colorectal
cancer. There is only one IO-based regimen,
which is the combination of the TKI zanzarlentinib with
atezolizumab. And here there is a response rate of
4% with a median OS of 10.9 months.
To the right, you see other approved regimens or single agents,
all of which have single-digit response rates and
median survival of 10 months or less.
This is for patients who have received two or three or more prior lines of
therapy. So again, major area of unmet need.
So let's look at the antitumor activity in this study.
First, the patient population is typical of a heavily pretreated
refractory population with a median of three prior lines.
Seventy-three percent of patients had liver metastases.
Now, the presence of liver metastases is an established poor prognostic
indicator and has been associated with lack of
response to multiple IO regimens, including
PD-1/CTLA-4 combinations,
including the second-generation CTLA-4 antibodies.
So this is an important
thing to note.
So the confirmed response rate here is 13%, with a disease control
of 50%. That compares favorably with the
monotherapy data from a different trial.
The major difference that you see here is in the disease control,
50% versus 27%, and less so on the response
rate front.
So my assessment here is that these responses are
intriguing for a chemotherapy-free regimen,
and especially that this antitumor activity is noted in a heavily pretreated
population that includes patients with liver
metastases and is possibly better than monotherapy.
What we do not know is whether the responses are durable,
if the stability is clinically meaningful and durable, and we do
not have survival data yet.
It was noted that the responses were clustered in
the higher weekly doses of the fusion protein targeting
FAP41BB.
However,
these cohorts are small in size and not powered to
be compared to each other for efficacy purposes.
Furthermore, there are imbalances in the baseline
characteristics of the weekly versus the every three-week
regimens. The Q3-week regimen had a higher frequency of
some of the poor prognostic and higher risk features,
such as more higher frequency of ECOG 1 patients,
more right-sided colon cancer, more RAS mutations, and liver
metastases.
Now, are there ways to enrich the patient population and optimize
tumor activity? Responses occurred in patients with or without
liver metastases. However, when I did a back of the envelope counting
on this slide, I note that there are fewer patients with liver
metastases on the response end of the
waterfall plot compared to the progression end.
Similarly, there is a tendency or a trend
for higher CEA expression H scores
on the response end, as well as fewer
patients with the immune desert phenotype.
Now, again, these are small numbers, but hypothesis-generating
observations that may be worthwhile further exploration in the future.
So how does this fit into the evolving landscape of immunotherapy for MSS
colorectal cancer? There's a lot going on in this space.
I cannot make it justice in the time I have left.
I will highlight two examples here, and I apologize for
not being able to mention every compound that's being evaluated.
So first with Bal. Botensilimab is an Fc enhanced
anti-CTLA-4 antibody when combined with dostarlimab and
anti-PD-1, there is a response rate of 17%
in MSS colorectal cancer with a median survival of 21
months. The responses were limited to patients without liver
metastases, and when we look at that group alone, the response rate
is 23%.
Another example is a bispecific antibody that co-targets
a PD-1 and the interleukin-2 alpha receptor.
So this is designed to optimize efficacy and minimize
toxicity. And as a single agent, there are responses
ranging between 7.7 and 13%, depending on the dose and
schedule, with a median survival of 16 months.
When combined with bevacizumab, the confirmed objective response rate
is up to 15%, but we do not have survival data yet.
Of note, I believe that the success in the
setting of MSS colorectal cancer will depend on smart combinatorial
approaches that target multiple pathways and multiple
inhibitory mechanisms simultaneously.
And the good news is there are multiple agents coming into this space and
actively being evaluated, as I tried to highlight here.
So here are my take-home messages for this abstract.
What we can conclude is that this is an elegant translation of a
preclinical hypothesis to a clinical trial.
The biomarker data from the trial are consistent with the scientific hypothesis.
The combination is clinically feasible with an early signal of
activity, including patients with liver metastases.
What we do not know is the optimal dose and schedule for the
combination. Survival data is not available yet.
Are there ways to optimize efficacy and enrich patient selection?
And it's still unclear whether the biomarker changes are associated with clinical
activity. Thank you.
Many thanks to both of our speakers.
The paper is now open for questions from the
audience.
I believe I see
a question here.
Thank you.
Beautiful talk. Thinking about next steps, you
saw that all the immune cells were still in the
fibrotic area, which makes sense because it's FAP
4-1BB. I wonder if you think if you switched out the FAP
arm for a tumor targeting antigen, if you would move the CD8 T
cells to the tumor and enhance efficacy.
You're right. We actually published in Nature Communication that
providing costimulation through 4-1BB and CIS with regard
to the antigen-presenting cell or the T cell engager
engaging cell is more powerful than provided it in
trans, although trans functions.
So that could be a potential improvement in that
direction.
What about a trispecific if CIS is the best?
Trispecifics are a possibility. Biotechnologically, could be
complex.
You would be needing to be creative.
But
we have seen some kind of crosstalk between
molecules. In the case of cross-linking,
probably would be a very good idea to have short molecular distances at
immune synapses.
Thank you.
Thank you. Question far to my left. Yes.
Yeah. Thank you. Excellent talk. Very exciting.
My question is twofold. What is the next step for this
combination given the outcomes that we saw?
And then are there other combination strategies that Dr.
Alkhouri kind of mentioned, targeted therapies, RAS inhibitors, that sort of thing?
So the main problem with this combination is the performance of the T
cell engager. That number one induces
ADAs, number two is not as safe as it
could be. There are alternatives in the T cell engagers that are in
the hands of the sponsors and other companies.
And what I think this communication is
going to be important is to foster the
concept of the combination of T cell engagers with inducible
costimulator ligands.
And in that regard, in the
realm of hematological diseases, combinations of a T
cell engager and 4-1BB ligand targeted to the
lymphoma cells with Blofetamab and Pomalidomide
have found extraordinary results in terms of
response rate that it's durable.
The previous question also alluded to RAS inhibitors.
Many patients had a RAS mutation, and so I'm wondering, did that
track with any biomarker or response?
And what do you think of the idea of adding in a RAS
inhibitor in terms of this immune mechanism?
I love it, Mr. President. But
no, the point here is that
yes, with larger number of patients, we would have been able
to really
conceptualize what's in there. In the paper in "Nature Medicine," we
divide the different CMSS groups, and you will see that some
of them seem to be, but it's tendency because of the low numbers.
Sure.
But you are going to find it very interesting.
And then one of my expectations for regimes like this one, we
and others have shown that cytotoxicity is a form of immunogenic cell death,
is that we will be creating endogenous immunization, maybe epitope
spreading because of the type of cell death that occurs.
And with the RAS RAF pathway inhibition, you
get some of that and it explains, for example, the combinability with
antibody drug conjugates. So,
thank you for the question.
That's great. We have final question far to my left.
Thank you. Beautiful talk. Very, very interesting.
Going back to the previous question, do you think that this
combination, I mean, the 4-1BB ligand could be amenable
to combine with the TCE with NY6
G6D
that was presented last year and maybe reveal more activity in
colorectal?
Yeah. Many T cell engagers. The problem with the target you are
referring to is the
number of cases that happen to be truly positive and not heterogeneous.
But certainly other T cell engagers
targeting molecules on the surface of colorectal cancer cells
would be amenable to the combination, which is
all these T cell engagers induce 4-1BB expression on the plasma
membrane, and thereby the T cells become amenable to costimulation.
Okay. We'll leave it at that. Thank you so much for wonderful work and a good
discussion.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
You are going to make president of the world.
So this brings us to our last presentation of the session,
from Dr. Pavlina Spiliopoulou
from University of Glasgow. She's going to be talking about a novel
vaccine targeting PD-L1 and IDO along with
Pembrolizumab for melanoma.
Hello, and thank you very much for this kind introduction.
And thank you to the organizing committee for inviting me to
present on behalf of all of my co-authors today, the
Phase 1/2 study mRNA-4359,
P101, with pembrolizumab plus
mRNA-4359 therapeutic in patients with advanced
melanoma and in the first-line setting.
These are my disclosures.
So beyond any shadow of a doubt, immune checkpoint inhibitors have
transformed the treatment of multiple solid tumors, but
foremost, the treatment of metastatic and advanced melanoma.
However, primary and acquired immunotherapy
resistance are still a major limitation, and a lot of our
patients have disease that is immunotherapy resistant and
have no several
therapeutic avenues after immunotherapy resistance emerges.
Now, mRNA-4359 therapeutic has specifically been
designed to address this immune resistance
by priming and expanding T cells that can
simultaneously recognize and clear PD-L1
positive and IDO1 positive tumor cells, as well
as immunosuppressive cells that express these antigens.
And this is an ongoing early phase trial that evaluates
mRNA-4359 as a monotherapy as well as in combination with
pembrolizumab
in solid tumors. And we recently
presented data on the combination of pembrolizumab plus
mRNA-4359 in patients with
immunotherapy-resistant advanced melanoma.
And we had a chance to prove that the combination not only
has manageable safety profile but has anti-tumor
activity and can mediate antigen-specific T cell
responses. So with the hypothesis that by adding
mRNA-4359 earlier in the patient's trajectory,
we hope that we can evade immune resistance, and hence today,
we are reporting clinical data, safety data,
as well as preliminary translational data on
mRNA-4359 plus pembrolizumab in the first-line setting for
patients with advanced melanoma.
So what is mRNA-4359?
It is a lipid nanoparticle encapsulated mRNA that
encodes both PD-L1 as well as IDO1.
IDO1 is indoleamine 2,3 dioxygenase, and it's a
tryptophan catalytic enzyme that essentially
depletes tryptophan. That leads to
dysfunction of T cells and activation of
immunosuppressive cells such as myeloid-derived suppressor
cells as well as T regulatory cells.
And that obviously mediates immunosuppression, which we obviously
try to avoid.
Upon intramuscular injection,
mRNA-4359 is taken up by antigen-presenting cells,
such as dendritic cells. It's produced and then
translated and then presented
in the cellular membrane
using the
major histocompatibility complex pathway.
This primes and activates PD-L1 and IDO1
specific T cells, such as CD4 and CD8 cells, that then can traffic
into the tumor microenvironment.
They recognize PD-L1 and IDO1 positive cells there,
both tumor cells and immunosuppressive cells, and can perform
immune clearance.
Now, with this mechanism, we can obviously cause tumor cell
kill and then further antigen release that then deepens and
broadens the immune response, especially when
combined with immune checkpoint inhibition.
So the mRNA-4359 P101 study
involved also patients with non-small cell lung cancer in its expansion
phase. But today, we're specifically focusing on the arm 2A,
which as mentioned, involved patients with advanced metastatic
melanoma.
So patients were treated on the right-hand side,
as you can see, with pembrolizumab every six weeks for a maximum of
two years, as usual, and mRNA-4359
intramuscularly injected at 1,000 microgram dose
every three weeks for up to nine cycles.
As an early phase study, the safety assessments
were the primary endpoint with adverse events and dose
limiting toxicities, and the clinical outcomes were the
secondary responses, such as overall response rate,
disease control rate, and duration of response.
The study also involved exploratory analysis, such as antigen specific
T cell responses and change in the TCR
clonality in the peripheral blood, as well as tumor-associated
biomarkers such as PD-L1 and IDO1.
So we have a median follow-up of 54 weeks
and a median mRNA-4359 exposure of nine
doses, which is excellent treatment exposure.
The median exposure to pembrolizumab was 6.5 doses.
This equates roughly to nine to 10 months, and we're
reporting
data on 12 patients so far treated.
Out of those 12 patients, seven have discontinued treatment either because of
adverse events or progressive disease, and five patients are still on
treatment, the majority of whom are on the maintenance part of
pembrolizumab.So the
baseline characteristics are listed here.
The median age was 58 years of age,
equal divide between male and female participants.
And as you can see, the majority of the patients had stage four melanoma,
apart from one patient who had unresectable stage three disease, which is still
considered quite advanced in the field of melanoma.
We looked into the PD-L1 expression intratumorally using
the tumor proportional score, so TPS score here.
And as you can see, the majority of patients had an expression of more than
1%.
The BRAF molecular status was again equally divided between BRAF
mutated and BRAF wild type melanomas, which is in keeping
with what we see in our clinical practices.
And as you can see, one-third of the patients, or 33% of the
patients, had received systemic treatment at an earlier age for
their melanoma, including immunotherapy.
It's also worth noting that one of the patients had a mucosal melanoma
and another one had acral lentiginous melanoma, which are behaving
biologically different than our traditional cutaneous melanoma.
So looking into the adverse events of the mRNA therapeutic,
as you can see, the majority were of low grade.
There were no DLTs and no toxicity more than grade
three, and luckily none of those adverse events
caused any discontinuation of both the mRNA or the pembrolizumab,
and thankfully no grade five events.
A serious event that is noted here actually
pertains to acute kidney injury in a patient with adrenal
insufficiency that was thought to also be attributed to
pembrolizumab as well.
In nature, those AEs
were very similar to the kind of reactogenicity that we
see with mRNA-based treatments such as
injection site pain, influenza-like
illness, and chills. And as you can see, all of those were
low grade
and of low prevalence.
When looking into the adverse events related to pembrolizumab, again, those
were in their majority of low grade, but we did see a
33% frequency of
grade three or four events, and 25% of our patients
discontinued the treatment due to those AEs.
But again, no treatment-related deaths.
The AEs observed at this point were
AEs that were immune-mediated in nature, as we see
with immune checkpoint inhibition,
such as pancreatitis, hepatitis, and
lung toxicity.
We did observe a grade four AE due to immune-mediated
pancreatitis, but it's worth saying that these were all
self-limiting and with no severe consequences for the
patients.
Focusing now on the objective response rate.
On the right-hand side, you can see all the patients of this cohort, and then
the patients are stratified according to PD-L1 status.
We saw an 83% objective response rate
in all patients with CRs and PRs and stable
disease that in the end equates to a 92
disease control rate. The median duration of response has not been
reached yet, and the time to response
was as brief as six weeks, which is good
to see.
Now, considering this 83% response rate, and to
contextualize this, pembrolizumab monotherapy in the seminal
studies had a response rate of 35%, say,
40%. So this 83% response rate
compares very favorably, but this is an extremely small sample
size of patients.
Now we can see the trajectory of the patients in a bit more detail
here, and it's worth saying that the majority of the patients remain
progression-free at this point, with three events of
progressive disease with multiple CRs and PRs, as you can
see. And the asterisks actually here denote patients who had
prior adjuvant or neoadjuvant treatment, so it's good to see that
patients can
experience responses even when re-exposed to some of those
systemic treatments. Obviously, the median PFS has not been reached yet,
as
you can see, because only three patients had an event of PFS.
Now the majority of the patients experienced a good
reduction in tumor burden, as you can see by this
waterfall plot, and
most patients had a PR or a better response,
and that was
independent of whether their tumor was
PD-L1 more than 1% or less than 1%.
And those responses, as you can see on the spider plot on the right, were
not only deep but were also durable, with some of the patients
experiencing those responses in excess of one year.
Now moving into the translational aspect of this study,
we performed bulk RNA sequencing on tumors at
baseline. And on the left-hand side, you can see the relation
between PD-L1 and IDO1 gene expression, PD-L1 expression
on the Y-axis and IDO1 on the X-axis.
Now all these patients had experienced clinical
benefit from the treatment, and you can see the nice co-current
expression of those two biomarkers.
And on the right-hand side, we show this in a bit more granularity
with a heat map of immune gene networks here, but
also in correlation with the clinical response on the top,
the TPS score on the second row, and then the gene expression for
PD-L1 and IDO1 respectively.And one
could potentially highlight patients in column one, three, and four
who seem to have had a high PD-L1 expression
intratumorally, but also and clinical benefit.
And in these tumors, we also had an
inflammatory milieu with upregulation of interferon
gamma
gene networks as well as antigen-presenting networks.
But having said that, patients who also did not have
a PD-L1 TPS high expression, they also derived the
clinical benefit despite the fact that they didn't have that
inflammatory type of tumor microenvironment.
And when looking into the biological activity of
mRNA-4359,
what we've performed was an interferon gamma
ELISpot. And on the left-hand side, you can see specifically for
PD-L1 and IDO1 T cell responses. This is an
interferon gamma ELISpot done on PBMCs extracted at
baseline and on treatment and expanded in
vitro, and the best ELISpot response was captured
here. We had six evaluable patients, and as you can
see, all of them
exhibited an increase in the antigen-specific T cell
responses for PD-L1 and IDO1
antigens. And on the right-hand side, you can see bulk TCR
sequencing done again in the peripheral blood.
And in all evaluable patients, we can see an increase in the de novo
clonal TCR expansion,
irrespective of clinical response.
And that would be in keeping with the fact that
the treatment can mediate TCR
engagement.
Interestingly, even a patient with progressive disease exhibited an
increase in their TCR clones, and this is someone who had a
response in their target lesions, but then unfortunately developed
hepatic deposits, which as we know are
a quite immunosuppressive environment.
So to summarize,
mRNA-4359 with pembrolizumab demonstrated a
manageable safety profile in patients who were
treatment-naive for metastatic or locally advanced melanoma.
Twenty-five percent of patients discontinued treatment due to
pembrolizumab-related adverse events mainly, but the rest of the
AEs were of low grade, and the AEs related to
mRNA-4359 were consistent with the
toxicity that we see with other mRNA-based therapies.
We observed an encouraging tumor activity with responses up
to 83% and disease control rate
92%,
and that was irrespective of the PD-L1 status or prior adjuvant or
neoadjuvant treatment. All evaluable patients demonstrated
antigen-specific T cell responses and expansion of their TCR
clones in the periphery, and which will be, again,
in keeping with the hypothesized mechanism of
mRNA-4359. And although this is a very small
sample size of 12 patients, we think that these findings support
further development of this combination in the melanoma
population.
So with that, I would like to express my gratitude to all the study
participants, their families and caregivers, and
everyone who contributed to the conduct of this study.
And I'm looking forward to the discussion with Dr. Allison Bethoff.
Thank you.
Thank you so much. And now to discuss this is Dr.
Allison Bethoff from Stanford.
Great. Hi, thank you, and thanks to the organizers for the
invitation. It's a pleasure to be with you and to talk
a little bit more about mRNA vaccines, which of course are a hot
topic and have been a hot topic at this meeting.
So these are my disclosures.
And of course, the study design which we just saw, and I wanted to highlight
just a
few key pieces of this study. So of course, we
have 12 patients, so caution us all from
over-interpreting 12 patients. Ten of which had
cutaneous melanoma. Overall, a relatively favorable
patient profile, reasonably low LDH,
very few patients with liver metastases, but overall a
good frontline melanoma patient population.
And I will also point out that three of these 12 patients
received prior immune checkpoint blockade in the
neoadjuvant or adjuvant setting.
Several of the patients did not, and one of the patients did receive
neoadjuvant nivolumab followed by
targeted therapy in the adjuvant setting.
And I will say that three of those four patients actually did respond to treatment.
So let's talk a little bit about preliminary efficacy.
I'm actually not going to talk much about toxicity.
This molecule is quite in keeping with other mRNA
vaccines that we have seen. And so I wanted to put this more in
context of where do we see this fitting in the frontline melanoma
setting. So these are the data that we just saw from
4359, an objective response rate in the frontline of
melanoma, 83%, with two complete
responders and eight partial responders out of 12 patients.
And you can see from the spider plots results
deepening over time and responses ongoing,
now quite durable.
So let's think about what our other standard frontline options are for
melanoma.So shown here in the middle are the data from the
CheckMate 067 study with nivolumab plus
ipilimumab with an objective response rate of
58.3%. You can see 24%
complete responders, 35% partial responders.
And of course, now we have 10-year overall survival data from this
study with a 10-year OS of
43%. And we know that the 10-year
melanoma-specific survival in this study was actually
over 50%. So truly game-changing in the
frontline and setting a very high bar for the frontline treatment of
metastatic melanoma.
On the right, we see data from the Relativity 047 study with
nivolumab plus relatimab. You can see an objective response rate of
43.7% with about a
20% complete response rate and 24% partial
response rate.
And the data shown at the bottom from the four-year follow-up from that
study with melanoma-specific survival, sorry,
overall survival in the 52% range and melanoma-specific
survival slightly higher than that.
So again, really high bar to come into the frontline in
metastatic melanoma, but early results that look promising.
I want to temper that a little bit. So we just saw
recently discussed at ESMO a
similar approach with
IO102/IO103 from Iobio combined
with pembrolizumab. And this is a
peptide-based vaccine targeting both PDL1
and IDO1. So very similar approach but
peptide vaccine versus an mRNA vaccine
approach. This was a global randomized phase three trial that I will
say was launched based on a very small phase one of
30 patients that looked similarly quite promising.
So just a little bit of temper here.
Similar patient population. Patients were randomized one to
one to either a peptide vaccine
plus pembrolizumab versus pembrolizumab alone, which many of
us would argue would not be the current standard of care for most of our
aggressive metastatic melanoma patients in the frontline, where we would
tend to use combination immunotherapy for these patients now.
Four hundred and seven patients and these are the data.
Primary endpoint here was progression-free survival
presented by Jessica Hassel at ESMO last year.
And you can see here
numerical differences in progression-free survival,
but these were not statistically significant.
This trial missed its primary endpoint
with a p-value greater than 0.05, and the statistical significance
p-value for this study was actually set at
0.045.
Interestingly, there were some key differences between
PDL1 positive and PDL1 negative patients.
Slightly different than what we just saw, which we'll discuss from this
mRNA vaccine, although very different patient numbers here.
But in the PDL1 positive patients in the
IO102/IO103 study, there were really no
differences at all in performance between the two arms.
But in the PDL1 negative patients,
pembrolizumab actually performed much more poorly,
and the vaccine did not add all that much
or didn't look significantly better
than in the PDL1 positive patients.
It's really that pembrolizumab did much worse in the PDL1 negative
patients.
So let's compare that to what we see from mRNA
4359.
So here broken down by PDL1
greater than 1% on the left and less than 1% on the right.
You see an 88% ORR in eight patients,
a small number of patients that are PDL1
positive and 67% ORR in three
patients who are PDL1 negative. But as we
saw responses in both of these groups.
So as we bear this out in much larger numbers, it's going to be really
critical to follow this. I will also just add the caveat that
of course the IO102/IO103 study uses
blinded independent central review, which we know is a more
rigorous criteria, and so we will need to see how this plays out
in a larger study using standardized criteria.
But I think overall, this speaks to one of the
key topics in our field right now is where are we going with
vaccines? We've heard about vaccines all weekend here at AACR
and for the last several years. Where are we going with this overall?
Are we going with peptide vaccines? Are we going with mRNA vaccines?
So I thought I would highlight this just briefly.
And of course, some key differences here.
Peptide vaccines, much simpler and less expensive to
manufacture.
mRNA vaccines, much more rapid and modular manufacturing.
And peptide vaccines that often require
adjuvants or optimized formulation and of course have to be
presented in HLA specific way versus
using the endogenous machinery when we give an mRNA
vaccine. Endogenous antigen production
can support both MHC-1 and MHC-2 presentation.
So
we think there are pluses and minuses to each of these approaches, and we've seen
successes and failures of each of these approaches.
But one key point of mRNA vaccines
that we often think about
is that mRNA vaccines may be broader with
multi-epitope targeting that may help reduce antigen
escape and increase T cell depth.That being
said, the expression levels may be really hard to tune because we
are using that endogenous mechanism.
I would also just highlight some key differences.
Again, we've seen data at this conference talking about personalized cancer
vaccines versus fixed antigen vaccines, and I'll
give a shout-out to Dr. von Der Heide, who
was calling these RNA medicine earlier, which I like.
So really thinking about some of the key differences here.
Of course, for personalized cancer vaccines, we have
patient-specific neoantigens, but we need to get that data
from complex tumor sequencing. That, of course, takes time.
That is expensive.
It targets non-self tumor-specific mutations,
which could minimize central tolerance and have higher T cell
avidity. But it is resource-intensive, it
requires complex bioinformatics, and for our patients with
advanced disease, particularly in the metastatic setting, turnaround
time can be really limiting. Versus a vaccine like this that
is off the shelf using shared tumor-associated
antigens. These are not patient-specific, but we know that
many of these tumors express these antigens.
More cost-effective, scalable, but of course have the risk of
immune escape and antigen loss, as well as the potential for
on-target, off-tumor toxicity. I did want to speak
briefly about this concept that we heard discussed
about the expanded TCR clones. So when I first saw these data,
I was very interested thinking about whether this was just from pembrolizumab
alone, since this is a frontline melanoma treatment
population. And so to try to put this in context, let's go
back briefly to data that were presented at SITC last year,
looking at this same combination in the
checkpoint refractory setting. And if we do that, we saw
exactly the same biology with increase in
TCR clones and novel TCR clones, even
in prior checkpoint exposed patients.
And so one of the key questions is going to be, what are those TCRs
targeting? Are they PD-L1 and
IDO multiple different epitopes, or are we talking
about epitope spreading? And I think we're really looking forward to seeing
some data there on antigen specificity.
So in conclusion, I will say mRNA-4359
plus pembrolizumab shows early promise with the caveat
of 12 patients and warrants further exploration in the
frontline setting. The safety was consistent with other mRNA
vaccine strategies, and we eagerly await the 2C
cohort, which is ipilimumab plus nivolumab plus
4359, which may be an more appropriate frontline
partner for these patients to determine the optimal
strategy. Translational data will inform us about the biology
of fixed antigen mRNA vaccines, for example, this question of
whether this is epitope spreading.
And some caution is warranted given the recent results from the IO102,
IO103 study targeting similar molecules. Thank you.
Okay. We have time for a few questions. We'll start here. Tony?
So
PD-L1 and IDO are immediate interferon gamma response
genes, stimulated genes, and the cells that make them go on to make over
a thousand other genes that help immune
responses to viruses, to bacteria, and to
cancer.
If the vaccine is successful as it seems
to suggest, do you think it's a good idea to have
lifelong or a persistent
immune response to cells that respond to interferon gamma?
Thank you.
I don't know the answer.
Yeah.
It comes up.
Yes. That's a great answer. Great question. And I don't have an answer.
Okay. Fair enough.
Over here to my far left.
Thank you for the really exciting talk.
Thank you.
I'm wondering, it's remarkable you didn't see much toxicity.
I would
expect the autoreactive T cells to cause some damage
on target on normal tissue, but do you
think there is a long-term autoimmunity risk
here?
Well, as we saw, obviously, there is a long-time autoimmunity risk with
immune checkpoint inhibition, and that's what we mainly saw on
this data. Now, RNA as a molecule...
Oh, am I not?
It's not on now. Go ahead.
Okay. Yeah, thank you for your question. Oh, so that's better.
Obviously, we don't have long-term data to see what the kind of long-term
autoimmune risk is there with the mRNA therapeutic.
And we know that immune checkpoint inhibitors themselves have
a long-term autoimmune risk with all the
immune-mediated toxicities that we know already.
So I guess more data and more time is
needed to see if there is a long-term risk with the mRNA therapeutic,
which, however, is kind of
biologically more likely to give you a more innate,
acute response.
So I would hope that this risk is not higher than the background immune
checkpoint inhibition.
And do you have data how persistent those
T cells that react to IDO and PD-L1 last?
So
what we do know is that with the passage of time and when the mRNA
injections stop, this reactivity seems to be
decreasing in time. And for that reason, this particular study
continues with an amendment to add vaccination every
three, ongoing vaccination, even after the nine first cycles,
every three months.
Thank you.
One last quick question, quick answer.
Oh, actually, two quick questions.
Two quick questions.
Could we comment on the toxicities derived from the vaccines that are
less than grade three, but serious?
So we only saw one serious event
attributed to the mRNA vaccine, and that was attributed to
both the mRNA therapeutic and pembrolizumab.
So all the toxicity was overall of low grade, grade one or two.
There were no grade three toxicities attributed to the vaccine.
If I may, just one very quick question, because Iobio Tech, the report is that
their response is HLA independent, but the
peptide is quite short. It's twenty to twenty-five amino acids, and
it's the same for Moderna's. I'm just curious whether
there's explanation for that, or have you looked at the HLA relationship with
the response? Thank you.
Yeah. We haven't looked into the HLA allele in relation to
response.
Thank you.
Well, I would like to thank all the speakers and the audience for their
participation in this session. Thank you.